And the answers here are that the shortest path from A to B has length 10,
so, for example here, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10,
and the number of shortest paths from A to B is still 2.
If you start on A, and once you've made the decision to go up here,
the only way to continue the shortest path is like this,
because otherwise he would be visiting a city more than once,
and then the path gets longer than 10 edges.
If, on the other hand, you start out by going down,
then there is no other way to go along the shortest path than this here.
So again there's 2 diffferent possibilities of going from A to B
along the shortest path that visits all vertices,
and the length of that shortest path is 10.